[Music]
good ol ffs music Miguel so late on a
Wednesday but you are gonna show off
some of the new Final Fantasy 15
expansion the multiplayer expansion
comrades we're finally able to I guess
create your own avatar so to speak which
we're gonna do right we're gonna start
from the very beginning and you can
either team up with you know potentially
three of your friends or you told me
earlier you could also play with AI if
for some reason you can find if people
to play with is that correct yes and I
found out that even if you do have real
people in your foursome and some of them
drop out in the middle of match they'll
just be replaced by AI oh sweet okay so
that's cool also just so you guys know
it's part of the season pass so if you
have that great if not you still need
the game but it's $20 right standalone
correct or will not standalone
necessarily but if you were to just buy
the DLC or the expansion rather it would
be $20 yeah you still need the full game
so we have a little bit of synopsis here
this happens I guess concurrently in
parallel with the main game plotline you
guys are soldiers of the Kings glaive
awesome subho sign
I'm doing well also just so you guys
know I will be monitoring YouTube and
twitch chat I haven't played this myself
but Miguel got a little bit of hands-on
time not not too much so we'll try to
answer your questions to the best of our
abilities butter Ranger and YouTube chat
saying the multiplayer actually works
pretty well so that's cool
was this a separate download yes I
actually had to go into the PlayStation
Store and download the expansion I went
to like there I guess what they call the
the homepage or the game page of 5se 15
and then I actually saw this thumbnail
for comrades it
sure it doesn't automatically download
Jesse's in Perico the low time is a
little long shadow but shadow Fox 57 but
I'm sure there's a lot going on here so
whoa just totally skip they'll be
amazing defenders of the crown all right
hear me
the power of Kings goes with you and
with power comes a duty to your kingdom
I think you'd appreciate your colleagues
infesting for the blessings of the stone
of Lucis your blade as well ray of the
hood clearing a path for the first track
star domain for characters but let it be
known your transgressions have not been
forgotten
once the true king awakens and the light
is restored to this world only then
shall you be forgiven and set free from
the burdens you bear okay bring this
back rise and shine okay you're probably
wondering what you doing here yep
alright what are we gonna make through
female let's do it is this worth
reinstalling Final Fantasy 15 asked
Alexander Wayne I think that if you have
the season pass you should I would say
you should probably want to try it out
seems like a pretty cool concept to me I
will like I said I haven't played this
is will be my first time seeing it kind
of outside of like trailers and I did
not check it actually now adds up if you
275 gigs
geez okay alright that I didn't notice
too much difference there but alright
seven hair choices like how the
character models there look different
though like that one to your right is
not what you would look like also it's
weird that oh you actually have to click
into it for it to switch okay it's not
one of those like you hover so you
feeling that look a little bit of the
side swoop bang as it were if I'm sure
alright that looks good okay
okay too much you don't want to do thick
thicker thinner eyebrows thick them you
know let's go number two option two yeah
okay
those could be tattooed on I barely can
tell the difference of that one oh no no
no no scars no face paint not even there
yet do you want a full body tip oh you
get a sleeve Oh keep going that's
definitely not there I wanted to believe
I wanted to arms for the tattoos that's
you sleeve you can change your voice
give me some voice at home okay hearts
and home okay sounds like lightning for
heart than home more like a lolly there
for hearth and home for hearth and home
for hearth and home
she's Owen as aggressive for hearth and
home aggressive tip for heart and home
or hearth and home or hearth and home or
hearth and home I was like boy the
hearth is home for Harvin home that's
all right all right so like home whoa
wow there's more than 15 four hearts and
hope for hearth and home yeah so like
like two through four we're like pretty
anime yeah yeah we're good alright
what's next okay
are you going tall short pretty average
Wow average there is like really tall if
like if the center line represents
average I'm not even there
yeah exactly let's go back to like five
six yeah that's good
just show me yeah yeah just show me
though the slider yeah that's good
that's good
oh wow she's giant she can't even fit on
the screen okay cool show me a full
weight I'm just curious
all right okay cool where are you okay
you're on the B okay
Wow her head got a lot bigger like how
the hair man you know what polygon is
gonna have a field day with this I feel
like potentially monster factories
interview
oh they didn't really the neck didn't
really do too much the head was more
prominent okay wider wider torso or
thinner torso all right
is this like how ripped her back is oh
it's like it's like part of the neck
kind oh okay yep as expected okay
oh you're gonna make a rip oh okay
that was not too bad okay give her full
dude you're gonna make her just ripped
out of her mind huh yeah okay
can you use Japanese voice uh I don't
know actually
we'll have to see I don't think it was
therefore there's been a trend recently
have a lot of niche Japanese titles
offering I want that to a language dude
I really want destiny to to have
Japanese that's so good in Japanese oh
is it it just sounds like I don't know
any time you hear a Japanese voice actor
like they're just so much more hype and
you don't always know exactly what
they're saying but they say it was such
you know ferocity sometimes Kaku cool
you know you just got back from Japan
right mm-hmm
oh man there's so many more options
that's all right all right you do you
Wow okay I have to say though at least
this character creator is legit pretty
legit more so than the game I just
mentioned destiny 2 there is way more
options going on here I don't know I
don't see a change in the Lipsey's oh
well I got lighter you you had a yeah
see like the shade of her lips is
slightly darker compared to I don't know
it's not going black though that's for
sure
I color oh that's hair color nice we're
gonna go make like lightning you're
gonna
do over nice the expansion is out link
to D past it came out today so if you
were interested and have the season pass
you can download it if you're trying to
get it ala carte as long as you have
Final Fantasy 15 it's $20 so yeah check
that out you got different color shirts
sure a color 3 just yeah pick one oh you
can you can look at this what that's
probably not even gonna matter too much
to be honest you're probably gonna end
up switching gear so fast yeah alright
next it's like a triathlon gear yeah
it's like you're ready to go you know on
a bike or swim she got T buzz on or
something for those of you know they
know the brand Eva's oh you can change
your shoes oh it's just the colors damn
it alright just it doesn't matter
alright next next that's it oh you
didn't even give us a final look
Oh what's her name it ain't black desert
though that's true AJ Santiago but black
desert was a like MMORPG Sam like
Samantha like when I got tricked and I
am Legend and was even more sad when Sam
died I'm not gonna say who Sam was or is
just in case no one's lost I am Legend I
don't want remember to remember the the
scene in there no clue in the rental
stone sweat it individual soul dramatic
and precious in your memories whenever
well was this rental story at all these
manic just like in movies also our
family Christmas hide behind her purse
and it's the Kingsley's job to keep her
safe from harm
yeah alright keep her safe better enjoy
the sunshine might at last they'll be
gone before you know it only the light
left in this world is the kind we make
ourselves cross face it is out you want
to try it plain it
you made a female avatar you can make a
male one let's hope that jog your memory
all of the Stalin's counting on us close
we are a glaive we fight for the game
Tristan clap you can play with AI if you
don't end up partying a little and as
Miguel had mentioned even if you are
part of a party if you happen to lose
any of your party members
it'll just drop in AI so it's not like
all right here are some tutorials so the
healing is not item base at spell base
okay and there's also some magic spells
okay
[Music]
nice a little you have these protective
barriers instead of with natural block
and chain warps
[Music]
all right let's give it a go
[Music]
yeah I always thought that was like the
funniest movie just warping around
so presumably if there's items as well
right
and while our goes as graphing items
I think items for food nice do some
cooking
what's up glade buddies yeah that guy is
still attacking now he's done yeah the
expansion s on a bus is $20 if you
didn't buy the season pass and this is
on the assumption that you already own
ff15 if you get into an obviously dinner
in total cost
I guess the PC version out my boy well
double check so that neither of us is
incorrect I had noted that this comrade
is available for ps4 and Xbox yeah when
I look at the con yeah so I for Conrad's
it says Xbox one ps4 doesn't say
anything about PC so it's fine not out
there yet but on console it is out for
both today November 15 all right their
reason for you to warp up to the top
don't worry
nope just keep going it was in the food
got some sirloin did you get that
sirloin
server issues on Xbox Live does a 16-bit
cupcake that's unfortunate if that is
actually the case I'm taking your word
for it
how about show us the game we are
showing you the game hopefully you guys
have seen that there's blocking
hit this we could go top lat
that is that's just the server no you're
good
I will fix that while you use
we got a big spider now
this also be a good time to mention that
we have our extra life charity marathon
this weekend
yeah it just so happens that we're gonna
have a ton of square enix game codes oh
not even including awesome fall fantasy
9 final fantasy 12 to zodiac a joke pal
fantasy xiv ok awesome yeah like that's
not the only thing we'll be giving away
but thinking to go but you know heads up
there there would be a lot of Giveaways
during that livestream thank you to
swear if they gave us some stuff to give
away though and also Ubisoft and a salir
yeah this all right we have 2 warps
nice work it's like a warp team you're
out of MP it's all good good buddies are
so good going to town it's hard to say
if $20 is steep considering the this
could last you a while but it's that
age-old argument of like you know dollar
value time value kind of thing
[Music]
I like that you have a baton at the
start
I think it's just kind of cool to have
your own avatar to you if you're like
that's part of the draw obviously and it
will add that you could create up to
eight characters Wow looks good though
and thankfully you don't need to go
through this initial area eight times
okay so you get to the hub world
I want to watch more but homework says
emo rekt oh that's okay man thanks for
stopping by you want to leave it on in
the background come back little bit see
how we're doing awesome if not you
should probably focus on your homework
I'll be in a responsible adults and say
you know chances are homeworks pretty
important don't know don't neglect your
studies our two thousand a skiing is
there not a multiplayer full open world
I don't know if we're we're like at the
opening tutorial area ish which is an
actual location in the overworld hello
have you gotten past like the hubby area
yet or did you kind of stop after I did
I completed a one quest okay
with parts not a fan of the loading
screen nor the social space yeah the
loading team could use a little bit of
work still well we'll see how much
loading we go through later they had the
real long wandering getting into the
game
in that hot MP motion
all right so now we're gonna enter the
set town just guys excited this is one
my favorite part is how they hide we I
don't think you got far enough to do any
summoning or anything like that right
yeah so unfortunately anymore I don't
have the answer for you there Michael
McCrory is asking or I think you
answered this earlier but I'll just ask
again but what time frame does it work
again or wouldn't is it during the game
is it in night in that gap slated and I
guess I'd say I think it's right between
chapter 14 or 15 or somewhere between 13
and 14 Antonio I'm sorry if I mixed up
my words it's not a standalone on its
own you have to own the game so either
there's getting the season pass right
now give you access to this expansion I
would think so yes yeah because that's
like essentially like buying you know it
should also get you so prompt Oh episode
Gladius and the upcoming episode Ignace
which is due out December 13th formative
gamer yes I guess that's I guess I can
understand why he's so mad he's an
informative gamer he's got all the
information
unfortunately we humans aren't faring
quite as well this is the only place we
can live nowadays and even then it's not
easy but the people of the Stalin the
ones were fighting to protect they
haven't thrown in the towel just yet
early 2018 as many have mentioned for PC
nowadays list alums known as the City of
Light the last speaking of hope left for
mankind that's why everyone's gathered
here refugees are pouring into the city
from all corners of the new cloud not
asking how many is it content-wise
hard for us to say we probably only
played collectively and mostly just
Miguel probably like less than an hour
yes I can't thank you enough so one of
the things you have to collect is these
things called meteor shards which
generate electricity throughout the town
and as you collect them through
completing missions you could start
empowering certain sections of the city
which essentially is wouldn't want to
face the wrath of core the impatient
there's something for the road sick Oh
daggers I get to pick your birthplace
which has that term in certain aspects
Oh Justine did you know what the other
ones were oh okay cool at least it okay
let's say did you just pick one and then
you're not gonna go magic let's be real
here
I thought your salmon your mm-hmm oh
that's what I would have picked all-out
attackers no MP necessary this guy looks
pretty well is like the tanky so what
are you gonna pick you know go with this
one okay so you picked like the typical
night class and she headed to yoga class
maybe Caleb we like to stay well fitted
for anytime you know anytime we need to
go swimming bike riding
you know we're ready for a triathlon let
alone you know destroying all that stuff
like this guy just see the back of his
head what's up sir
I'll make sure to get the cameraman
arrays oh right I suppose I ought to
introduce myself
I have Dourdan president and CEO of
meteor publishing incorporated you see
that shot of you made quite a splash
among the locals so I was hoping you
might let us take some more our resident
cameraman will just follow you around
and snap some shots but don't worry he
won't get in your way
come on the public is eating you up
let's give him another helping
so you're the glaive everyone's been
talking about pleasure name's gene I
work for exonerates we take the meteor a
to ask you can a square enix given any
hints as to what the plan for conrad is
going to Ford is it going to be like a
service or just admitted question I do
know that they're going to incorporate
the the main for some of the story in
the game but beyond that I don't know
we'll have to see
Dimitri Jack has yes this is available
either to purchase for $20 if you
already own the game or you can buy the
season pass or if you have the season
pass you should be able to just download
it okay so now I see what you're talking
about kind of unlocking the town right
and as a result yeah I have a hunt
mmm-hmm it's time to hunt them
Ziya
these tasks aren't for the future
something is do you have what it takes
have you actually said anything you know
we picked the voice mm-hmm I don't know
if we've said anything which is
interesting $20.00 King pancake if
you're just buying it on its own or you
could buy the season pass thank you
all right we're searching for players
for a hunt so as someone said it's kind
of like Monster Hunter ish I guess you
could say there in that regard and the
season passes $24.99 you get the holiday
pack the booster pack episode gladion oh
[ __ ]
oh hello tech doors or pack door
it's a practice on oh that's okay
episode in this episode prompt oh and
then you get the comrades as well
obviously you would need PS Plus and
Xbox Gold if you're gonna be playing
online it is also out in the UK as
Daniel R has mentioned not just the u.s.
I believe hi hello John hugginson
alright we're with Gordon Ramsay's Chef
Ramsay's man Hell's Kitchen that's chef
himself while your level okay everyone's
little one that's okay so is it mainly I
mean I'm ignorant and I'll be honest
about it is it just mainly surrounded by
hunts or is there other things as well
I've only done hunts okay and they've
only been like monster hunts so I'm
gonna prepare for requests I'm hoping
there will be some humanoid antagonists
at some point okay
grabbing some supplies I will ready up
in the hopes of encouraging everyone
else to radio so that we don't have to
wait the 4 minutes and 35 seconds that's
left yeah but that said thanks in
advance guys for sticking around while
we wait for this countdown to go down
yeah well well 101 says he's got some
veggies
well on Alex oh man alex is swaggin look
at that jacket we're living that casual
exercise life I mean even Gordon
Ramsay's got a nice little coat hood
hopper says this looks lit yeah have you
picked a class or anything like that at
all yet no okay I just picked my my
background yeah just your background
which affected some of your stats right
so we'll have to see pkt
but we are on our first hunt with Sam
Rudo and chef Gordon Ramsay spelled with
some numerical numbers numbers
oh great
have you used very much of the magic at
all find out a little bit that guy's
trying to block oh man that guy had a
little down strike
that's the only thing was better than
the main game if you didn't like the
bros not just anything his buddy fresh
tripe that's not what's right okay so
the war points to get some MP pack which
is the parties engaged with something
one thing I'm not fond oh really
I love try it that's great just lead in
some crazy gb stir one it's not a pre
expansion either you bought the season
pass or you can buy this multiplayer
comrades expansion for $20 Renan Lopes
says Ramses is dressed like cipher from
ff8 I only played ff7 the best one come
at me I know there's some I know Callie
doesn't think that that's why I like
saying it when I can especially when she
can't do anything she found out that
Kelly's favorite Pokemon is not even
Pikachu oh yeah yeah Kyle beer says I
love this game is this enough to get
back into it again I take it with a
grain of salt because I've only seen a
little bit of this but I figure you know
anytime there's a game you really enjoy
and you like you know kind of combat
this kind of just gives you a reason to
do more of that oh what's this oh it's
the boss yeah and the little girl was
just in the shot using the way she wore
pup that
Oh Ramsay's Chef Ramsay's was like yeah
I got the memo repping his high level
these fellows it's a year
you're taking some damage there
sadly you don't have any info oh if
someone's healing though that's good
thank you
Oh came that warp our one triangle
you're about to go down
Oh
take that
give me your meat Chef Ramsay's needs to
cook this is included in the season pass
Mecca we did it
who did you get an item there are some
okay three pieces of meat thick shank I
think you can only care one piece of
food at a time
now Genesis from what I can tell so far
at least with the multiplayer is you get
to this first hub world
you got to collect these meteor shards
which will then kind of grant more power
to the town which ultimately gives you
more like quests right mm-hmm welcome
back oh thanks Monica it's good to be
back okay so something I got tripe
everyone just got food which is gonna
make our lunch barely looks good
good thing I had lunch or that would
make me hungry we're getting with the
offal for lunch today I just like a
couscous spinach salad thing from proper
foods all right
I have no idea how long it'll take to
complete Daniel Kennedy I Otis I would
have to think that like a multiplayer
like this is gonna take quite a while
just because there's got to be some hot
replay value right and as someone
mentioned this does allow you to kind of
make your own avatar in the ff15 world
and there's some different classes I
believe we haven't gotten that far yet
though so Tony pin rut we are currently
playing on a normal ps4 he said that the
game seems to be running pretty well
yeah we were just on a normal uh yeah
yes war do you know if this is
peer-to-peer or is it a dedicated server
that I do not know I do not know yeah
unfortunately sorry that I don't have
the answer to that no one alive I'm not
gonna get into console war chatter Jesus
Perez I feel like you're baiting a
response here the only thing that has
sort of mildly annoyed me so far as
these loading screens are kind of long
but I kind of get it cuz you got a load
back into this big town so you're kind
of like instancing into something else
in a way so you didn't get any meteor
shards from that right you just kind of
was just one of the quests I think you
actually do okay oh fashion yeah fashion
no how do we turn the power on alright
we actually have to make the connection
first we need to shop you know I'm about
fashion oh yeah that's the apparel yeah
let's get let's do it I don't care
okay the streams only have about an hour
to 90 minutes we might as well get our
our money's worth at the store nice
thanks again oh you're welcome maybe now
we can go from like exercise clothes to
something I don't mean to bother you out
of the blue but would you be interested
in buying some used clothes it's for a
good cause I mean they're not all used I
actually sewed some of them myself
anyway have a look if you got a second
yeah what do you got oh my god the
cheaper because it's secondhand watch oh
you have praise books which apparently
can help our one
we don't need phrase books nor oh
there's the oh is that the tattoos you
gotta buy them oh damn it alright well
skip that too ooh look at these boots
gloves striped t-shirt well some glasses
get some glasses oh yeah you can oh look
at you we are now broke instead of
weapons we bought accessories that's
right now you want to equip that
yeah
oh I'll actually have all we had gear
dang it
come on all right we'll just put it on
boys
put everything else on there's no equip
option it's just check won't check what
items no there's gotta be away but
there's yeah I mean just a dress-up area
I think well I don't want to change my
character Jason I could assist with no
that's not it
maybe it's edit
all right please a tire top yeah yeah we
you bought it you might as well but I
bet the jacket looks pretty good
damn all right just go with the shirt
you paid for it it goes bad when you uh
we bought something you know where I
next now you have the rest of everything
no yeah yeah but you can wear everything
else though so you should be equipped
like the everything else yeah put some
match with your sandals yep
yeah get some boots yeah and that's good
we're going for that business casual
look with keeping it with what's outfit
okay whatever that's good
finish yep great what is this another
avatar
whatever I'll Sam - Sam - as well so do
you have to change to that okay let's
see so we'll find out we'll find out
oh yeah all right we stylin now all
right what next Miguel you quest see if
I could power up another area what's up
how much you darn right you do oh yeah a
lot of kilowatts to give right now it
just depends on where you want to go
whoo that's a lot that was like more
than half man we got a we got a question
all right cool let's go on a hunt it
sounds like you're fighting a spider
ready to get powered see ya where is the
talk of the town kids
thanks to those photos depends on where
it you opened up an area right I think I
see a really camera viewer on top goth I
bought him yeah I've seen a lot of crowd
wait that's no no that's might be in the
power plant no no check the map seems
like a wise choice
I'm Matt what's up okay
so you opened or wait I can open up this
one as well okay
by now goodbye our words are said quest
is it that guy we got oh no he had
weapons that's fine you already own that
and you're right
oh you somehow got money I guess by
opening up areas you get money okay nice
I'm not sure Tony pin rod if it's just
hunting missions as mentioned we just
started so that's what's been available
to us hard to say if that trend will
continue but possibly we're trying to
find our next hunt which Oh
listen like I guess worn like on the map
it kind of looks like it's through there
yeah I peered over the ramparts to get a
look at the situation outside and I wish
I hadn't those demons are terrifying
well where are you relative to the map
now are you closer to that area that you
opened no I thought I was what's up
north that way is there anything check I
don't think it's that way though I'm
with it wraps around we will find out
not many people know this but the folks
who founded nope locked up a side path
here the lavell is off-limits to regular
civilians for the time being the city
wants to make sure we save space a
digits sha you if you don't have the
season pass or the actual expansion then
you won't have it it's paid DLC oh wait
cuz they're right here this whole time
yes that wasn't super I don't know if
you can do level 4 I mean you could try
your level one so much else to do it
play baby well yeah I would depending on
well we'll see how bad this one is right
like I would just if you had to you'd
have to just keep farming the level one
one which doesn't sound like a lot of
fun no one alive I don't think you can
customize the run animation sorry you
can't run like Naruto if you tried that
in real life I don't even think it makes
you run faster
I wish you a safe return moreno Kodama
one saying it is how based missions yep
all right we are with two level twos and
a level one they all have the Oracles
sigil healing light which we don't have
hmm must be a quest item or a reward
from something but we look good though
t-shirt and glasses you know much higher
HP than they do but their MPs much
higher if you're looking for the game on
the store you have to look for a Final
Fantasy 15 and then I believe you will
then see the comrades expansion there
wow you have a lot of life somehow you
only had like 500 earlier hmm did you
equip your mace or is that just one of
the weapons at all okay at this point
maybe not
oh I can only adjust
all right we're going Mase oh you bought
two weapon don't even see all right we
are ready we have four weapons now
is this one person not readying up no
we're already the game - thanks everyone
for tuning in we are currently checking
out wow fantasy 15 s a new expansion
multiplayer expansion called comrades my
name is Eric that's Miguel Miguel is
currently playing for us and we got our
nice little t-shirt glasses and military
combination and yeah we'll soon get into
some combat here this is our second hunt
looks like we're hunting a spider so
yeah it says waiting for comrades though
so that's weird I feel like someone
didn't ready up on on the team or
something whatever otherwise we've gotta
wait three minutes until it starts and
that's when they'll start oh there you
go everyone's ready now right I saw it
Oh Shiro unready is it just I guess
everyone ready doesn't mean anything
right now
might just set the way for the counter
could also just be day one you know
well hopefully it starts at a zero
because I'd be really awkward doesn't do
you play I didn't play a very much a
fifteen did you play a lot of 15 i
Platinum 15 Wow okay excuse me yeah
you're excused
so it sounds like you enjoyed the game
quite a bit Ryota platinum it pulled put
in about a hundred five hours
awesome yeah though that said I only
have two other Platinum's I think I may
have one other plan well doesn't that
speak volumes of how much you like this
thing event yes and the other platinum
all you had to do was beat Game of
Thrones telltale
so yep we're currently waiting for this
hunt to begin it's weird because
everyone has readied up but it hasn't
started so hopefully the quest will
begin when the countdown reaches zero as
it says there it specifies oh she's
going for that half casual half business
look to this person we can do it you
guys have questions or anything like
that send it our way we'll try to answer
them to the best of our ability
we've Miguel's only probably put in less
than an hour though so this is why as
far as he got before we started playing
today so you're curious we're not too
far into how far you would be if you
were playing yourself I went live today
so damn aru can I play it in
single-player do I need to be online
every time I would my assumption is
you'd probably have to be online it is
online multiplayer but maybe I think yes
demented gear when ff7 eventually the
remake remastered whatever you want to
call it comes out it is gonna be in
chapters at least what they said
previously
well legends faith no you don't just run
around you technically you know we'll be
fighting monsters and eventually a boss
monster of which will then get boots and
you'll go back to the hub world and then
unlock more power for other areas and
new quests warlock khayru explores the
first hunt we did we did not have to
wait the full four or five minutes and
we're stuck at zero now yeah so it could
just be some day one woes I don't know
can you exit the hunt and refuel or is
that not a possibility
I can't even pause the Mesa so it's cool
so can you unready what does that do for
you
someone hungry and readied or what is
rest to do nothing cancel
all right that's very awkward okay
here's what we gonna do Miguel we are
gonna go full camera here and you're
gonna kill the kill the app for me and
then restart the app that's what we're
gonna ultimately have to do I feel like
we're stuck right now like I said it is
the first day of the comrades
multiplayer expansion everyone was ready
there even the countdown went off and it
didn't you so we'll try again the same
hunt and hopefully it works this time
and if for some reason it doesn't then
we'll stop but I think I think you
should be alright I think it was just
probably just a bug and we will overcome
that bug here someone saying you can
play offline game SWAT noobs that's news
to me I'll take I'll take a look at that
if that is the actual case I just
figured that if it's a multiplayer
online kind of thing that you would be
you know needing to be online but you
know well what we can do is we could go
with the recruit AI option this time
okay we'll check that out I guess in
theory I could unplug it and you can see
if it works alright
all right here we go what's on the
top-left side of the shelf like above
like right here or behind Miguel because
it's I always have to remember that
we're like on the opposite so if it's
this right over my shoulder where I'm
pointing
that's a revenant from doom if it's over
Miguel's shoulder it's Reinhardt so yeah
yeah your PC's gonna be waiting a while
apparently early 2018 for ff15 pc just
so you know more loading yeah the first
time we loaded it took a hot hot second
so we just did that Jedi kill it so we
have closed the app and we reopen it so
hopefully now that we are reloading it
we will try the AI mode as McGill had
just mentioned and there's a nice time
to remind you guys that we're gonna have
our extra life charity livestream
marathon this weekend where we'll be
giving away a lot of games and
merchandise and especially a number of
Square Enix titles including 5se nine
twelve zodiac age fourteen Nier automata
world of Final Fantasy i'm setsuna and i
think I'm missing something else yeah
the fact that you remember that many is
pretty impressive
it is so you know tune in on Friday as
we'll be playing games for the kids and
possibly doing some stupid stuff for
money for the kids and yeah it should be
a fun time it's gonna be 72 hours were
you playing on your time slot I don't
know yet I got into the we did like this
youtube post community post yesterday to
kind of ask what people wanted us to
play or games they wanted to see and
there was a couple of people that wanted
Dark Souls 3 neo and like blood-borne
and those are right up my alley so if
nobody else is playing some of those
games I'll probably play some of the
that I just mentioned there and they'll
be interesting to the three other people
that you're playing with I don't know
too bad so sad I'm doing I'm doing 6:00
a.m. to 12 p.m. I figure there's some
leeway there to play something all right
maybe I don't play all three maybe I
just play one of the three and I was
trying to think of like things that we
could do to gonna get like we're not
playing on PC right now this is ps4
things that I could do to help kind of
drum up interest to help kind of
devotion so I got Nick in my group and
we're at least for one half hour section
of the two hours are playing we are
going to do Call of Duty one-on-one
gaming elite as based on where we're at
in the game right now it's a hub based
and we haven't been able to kind of like
roam with everybody outside of like the
Hunts
so yeah we're gonna jump into this
mission hopefully this quest here with
some AI and hopefully this time around
it it works right away sand so we are
with just some AI should be able to
hopefully trigger this a little bit
faster is the hope got some veggies whoo
okay hello madam
you're only one person right now all
right we have two people Delilah and
Jenica Delilah must be healer because
she said her health is in her hands oh
that was instant we gotta get that that
sigil that they got all right well we
got in right away with AI the other
thing I guess I could test for you at
the very end of this is I'm gonna unplug
it to see if you can actually play
offline as one person mentioned and
called me a new for not knowing which if
that is the case and I was I wasn't I
got this a ha ha I'm probably
a wo x Juggalo 420 that's long name
you can play it right now if you have to
see them pass or if you just want to
purchase it for ignite 2009 you use your
mates
Oh your bindings are gone that sucks oh
yeah that's all right
I can't wait to see the big tarantula
looks like one of your teammates is a
very defensive type ai
so that's kind of those classes coming
to play which we haven't
juban 23 I don't know if we're gonna I
don't think we're gonna do anything
review wise for the multiplayer Conrad
probably not Vonzell marketing
reinstalling now I want to experience
this for myself
cool I hope you can have some fun making
your avatar and getting in on some of
these hunts
oh is that the boss probably not
- easy thing to easy to early hominid
barrage is what this movie is called
alien carrier
I'm sure there might have been a facial
hair option for the
maybe I'll play some tattoos after this
I'm just gonna live with tattoo
regression
stuff I guess in this game is this my
grandpa no this isn't yu-gi-oh I'm not
Yugi and that's not grandpa he didn't
give me my deck berta and told me to
believe in the heart of the cards sorry
i never watched you ukyo was on twitch
at marathon the other week so i was
watching the front of season 1 and
reliving my childhood believes in the
heart of the card
hey everyone tried to warp there and
then we got there first oh damn this
Moses
more than I guess do you look cooler
coming in though
[Music]
yield
Oh number two
I imagine it's also being more fun to
like if you have a couple buddies that
are playing about 15 club
some punts together
that's cool I wish my grandpa played
video games with me is what to cloud
says I don't think my grandpa ever
played in Japan but he definitely
bothering something that's weird
you think that there we go
what's up Carolina Pizarro I'm saying
hello the George Barbour channel this
does cost money
$20 either if you're just buying this
multiplayer Conrad's mansion on its own
for $24.99 with the season pass which
gives you a bunch of other content as
well a bunch of episodes all right not
bad for playing three levels below mine
yeah it didn't seem that hard the other
weird thing to me is like technically
you're like level one right but those
monsters are level nine so I don't know
scaling doesn't seem quite as accurate
there but all good
I can't Bobby get to level two after
this okay hope so and I had no notable
contribution you were almost the highest
in offense but not really but that
character is level five defense was nice
so you know I have more damage than you
Vonzell mark I didn't see the Cloud
Strife hairstyle
in the character creator the avatar
creator but we made a female characters
Wow look at that creamy meat and veggie
saute lots of mushrooms some type of no
meat
what's up Hugo Estrada and Ricardo
Nicoli yeah bonds I'm mark if you own
ff15 you can either buy this on its own
$15 or just Josh 399 64 these servers
are online so if you have this for ps4
or Xbox one you can go ahead and do this
a little bit power I got that's quite a
bit of power singularity blonde from
what I can tell right now I there
doesn't seem to be free roaming but
we're very early on not sure if anyone
else in Chapman may or may not know if
they've been watching other streamers
kind of get farther in the game but for
now we've only done two hunts and kind
of unlock some areas we made our
character we've kind of bought some
clothing some new weapons that oh you
need to equip that by the way right this
is a part of the season pass is not free
Billy Papa
or you could just buy it not part of the
season pass and just buy the comrades
expansion on its own
hot loading though hot diggity load do
Co spook asking I didn't know even
though this was out do you feel it was
worth the cost of the season pass I will
let Miguel's I think it adds value to
the season pass whether or not you want
to buy it individually for $20 I'm not
sure yet well at that point if you're
gonna spend $20 do you think the $5 is
worth it for the three episodes right
yes then there you go then you're
probably better off buying it Oh does
that let you get to that next area yeah
why don't you unlock that and open up
the PowerPoint oh we can't these are
okay it's got a trick or something right
we've unlocked all the power start
receiving regular donations okay to work
okay Holly ooh
solo question thanks again is she near
the photos yes used to think that gods I
read about in the cosmati need come to
save us that ain't true gates that good
what's up game sooo perfect
well well welcome to the glade her
clothes but I need your help with
something
otherwise the whole time yeah well let's
get to work Shep yeah let's get to work
I don't know what that is gonna be but
we will see so yeah there seems to be a
single-player component to this helps
mix up the game descent into darkness is
the quest camera there purposely making
a look
start a comrade up there Sam I can't
even add it to you
sorry well the ropeway are in your left
that's what you'll the plant and if the
plant loses power so does the entire
grid okay we definitely don't want that
chest back in there they're like a pack
of rabid dog but more demon like all
right so you got igniting work on your
own
nice yeah yeah guys tell you to after
this quick amazing yeah that is correct
for all those people asking this
attention is $20 or you could buy the
season pass 25 in which case Miguel said
that the five dollars extra you're
spending probably worth it for the three
episodes as well as when we pull up what
you get the holiday packed the booster
pack episode gladiator buddy Ellis
ignition and Prompto and then
hi James Davison okay so far there has
not been any open world stuff right here
also that sucks Taylor Gang says head
his expansion still hasn't done
downloading he and he started at 11:30
it's a quite a while ago I'm going to
put it in rest mode if you're on a ps4 I
hope that that saves you some time
halo one crisis says so far for them
it's been worth it I mean they've been
enjoying it quite a bit that's cool oh
no killer bees
what was your favorite weapon site 2015
a particular high-level javelin that I
used for a very very long time
dan the new the other person on stream
today is Miguel concepción I'm one of
the editors the editorial side not to be
confused with a video editor Oh
comrade has healed you even though there
is no comrade alright I know that like I
guess you can't die
well maybe you only get one of those for
free
we'll see if you have the season pass
pork laughing then it's yes it's part of
this enterprise I wouldn't say it's free
though I mean you paid something so this
was released today though James Jarmon
asking do you think they'll keep
multiplayer if they're able to port ff15
to the Nintendo switch I mean if they do
keep multiplayer they'll have to if
they're gonna do any type of cross play
don't have to be with PC and Xbox one
not PS war though same with like how
rocket leagues when you're going on come
on I would say user error oh my girl
okay you know
there's gotta be something you're
supposed to work through right right
boom nailed it
do what sign asking do you recommend la
noir on the switch hard to say we won't
be having the review of that at some
point are you supposed to work there
maybe Matt Espinel he's on the case he's
currently been playing it so we will see
oh you finished mm-hmm okay let's see
what you get yeah we'll have to see if
it how that goes James Jarmon hard to
say Dan the noobs go-to weapon was a
great sword we get back to is it lit or
[ __ ] don't know I'm in the middle right
now alright so what do you have to do oh
it's another little side question yeah
with the power for new areas
oh so hopefully we have enough power to
do that yeah let's find out oh you got
plenty of power okay
oh you're just short the quest or you
just have to do another one of the ones
that was already there right I can
barely keep up with you oh boy oh yeah
2400 power Oh
let's see what time it is good luck to
you that's up to you I mean we can do
one more hunt if you want otherwise see
what Sid is going on Sid I can craft
regi security detail you didn't help him
much but maybe you can do something for
me oh he's got question the camera zone
show if I missed your question I
apologize you can ask again usually if
you guys would question in front of it
it makes it easier for me to read oh so
there's the others the correct an
opponent to this game halo 1 Christ is
saying I like how on this DLC you can
upgrade the weapon your weapon the way
you wanted anything new for characters
like new magic weapons not have you
noticed anything off the bat it's it's
very early for us
Andros 1 5 6 yes but I am using some
items right now ok yeah so he says
what's up game the cameras don't show
guy basically asked us what's up case
why are you guys playing the multiplayer
mode for a 15 yes we are thank you for
tuning in sorry I missed your question
so you created this character you play
with who though so you play you make
your avatar and you can either play with
the AI or the game will queue you up
with other people that have made it so
right now we're just messing around with
the crafting or upgrading here so he's
strengthening his katana level 19 out of
30 so the attack has gone up quite a bit
I believe that basic like before you
upgrade it it was like 24 so now it's
getting getting up there I didn't even
see you using a katana that much but
you're gonna upgrade it in so Dan Lee
who says yeah beta had new weapon types
like hammers and shuriken thank you Dan
the new did you stop playing destiny Dan
and mood
legend paid through saying I love the
fact that you can either play story mode
or jump into the multiplayer to play
co-op a nice touch I guess there is
where we did just do some single-player
stuff on our own
what's bone crusher well you got bone
crusher now seems like an ability for
your katana standard attacks have a
small chance of reducing enemy attacks
by 10% you wanna go on a hunt then then
we'll call it or you want to do some
shopping one with the blade what we're
doing on Friday we're doing stuff for
charity
I would like to shop with you Maxie I
round up for you what is the best final
fantasy for me I mainly only played a
couple ever oh man
so my ff7 story's a little sad I played
through all the way I was on you know
Sephiroth at the very end and my save
got corrupted so I ultimately had to
play on a friend's save but that friend
had Omni slash and knights of the round
which kind of makes it laughable at that
point I played the crap out of f of 10
and even x2 had to beat that had to beat
that twice to get the good ending so I'd
probably go 7 or 10 for me personally
but there are other good ones like mine
and some people say 6 right what's your
favorite FF 12:12 that was instant yes
you can team up with AI knights knives
so what did you just do hunt yeah okay
we're gonna finish off strong here on a
hunt is this one with ai ai with the AI
because that was reliable versus spiders
our first hunt we were able to keep up
with other you know players online and
there it was fine for summaries
our second time around when we when we
queued up
we were queued up with other players and
we were all at the base camp which is
right here for some reason even though
we already dumped it didn't ultimately
work for some reason so we had to back
out but it's why I just day one kind of
stuff that they're dealing with so it
happens halo 1 Christ is saying yeah
mine is 7 and 10 Moreno kagame 1 8 and
12 here yeah if you guys uh why aren't
you guys in chat tell us what your
favorite FF game is of all time where FF
games Aran King saying 12 was pretty
good
so yeah I still don't know why you don't
have the sigil I bet we're missing
something
you got the sigil fight yeah whatever
using some of those weapons
Carmelo Romano FF 13 was the best one
just kidding go kill him
yeah I really wanted 13 to be good
like and that was lightning right like
that was the game that I bought ps3 for
Wow because I was like dude ff13 looks
sick and then no no I played okay so my
problem was I played up into the point
where I was like right about to get to
the good part which is supposed to be
like when it opens up and you can fly
around right I just couldn't get myself
to that point I'm just like no I can't
do this anymore and I stopped playing
so that was your system stellar know so
that was a main reason to why I bought a
ps3 but then you know it didn't come out
for like what a few years something that
it was a while so when it come out those
three years okay even worse yeah Dan the
noobs favorite ffs are between 7 10 or
15 Wow 15 up there pretty nice what was
your xbox 360 system oh I didn't have a
360
I pretty much have had growing up and
even now I guess I've only ever had
Nintendo so I had an NES a Genesis ps1
ps2 ps3 ps4 and then I had a switch and
I had a Sega Genesis oh and in 64 is
well sorry just forgetting you know when
you're like younger you can't have it
like you only have one or the other
right so that's what happened cam Jones
only FF game he ever beat was seven my
system seller for ps3 was male Gear
Solid four okay that's a good one and my
system seller for Xbox 360 was fantasy
star universe which was regrettable
so now halo not halo
all right get some MP back oh that guy's
got a gun or no air-bone arrow crossbow
sorry have you been able to mess with
any of your skill stuff yet like that an
option okay I really haven't had the odd
all right so we're in this area where
there's a couple boxes all his AI
teammates are little five somewhat
asking fire there's one that last party
that had this nice defensive ability
feel like your katana is doing a lot
more damage than it was
you did double the power essentially how
is this mode I don't know I should ask
him to go because he's only playing that
I'm redoing a mission just to grind I'm
hoping more Clarisse oh well you just
need to use your power oh I guess you
would have had to have done this
regardless actually as soon as I say you
were just limited by the fact that you
did have enough power but you got
or you definitely have the beauty's
mission to get one power and I don't
think he really misspent any power
because you had we had to unlock
everything the first time to get through
yeah no problem the cams don't show I
just sometimes I miss check because I'm
watching what they're playing and I
don't always stare at chocolate yeah no
problem
always a pleasure to answer people
questions so yeah wolves unlock this
next thing and see what that does and
then we'll probably wrap it up
is this a 4 man co-op multiplayer it can
be more eolmana say if we had queued up
in a hunt it would try to search for
other players doing the same hunt and at
least so far and you just do that type
of mission there with others nice look
at how much that katana of great did for
you
2 4 6 black started this is out today if
you own the season pass or if you want
to purchase it it's 1999 it's not a free
DLC all right we're gonna get some food
now how long have you been playing Final
Fantasy so for me my first one was 7 so
I was white like sixth grade or
something like that we're gonna shower
age right now we go my first one was 7
oh and I was 21
nice you probably had a better grasp of
the game that I missed out on all the
Final Fantasies on the yeah I did - I
did - was a Genesis kid yeah same cam
zone show I would think that this is
kind of like doesn't matter if you how
far you are in the story because this is
kind of separate from that so I'm sure
you could just hop into this if you
wanted to but obviously you bought the
base game so if you you know you want to
just hop into this then you just have to
buy the bots or I've had the season pass
or just bought this thing this comrades
expansion on its own Kingdom Hearts got
me into this game oh that's that's a
good point
mmm you know hearts I know that Peters
not the biggest man of Kingdom Hearts I
always thought it was cool but I think
that you have to kind of have that
affinity for square like you know square
and is
so if you don't have that affinity for
Disney I can see why I like it doesn't
matter to a lot of people but I just
remember seeing my my college roommates
playing Kingdom Hearts and I was like oh
that's really cool like you know like
the like seeing Donald and like goofy
and stuff like that running around
beating stuff up it's cool to kind of
get in its like hop into those worlds
like the last Kingdom Hearts trailer was
Toy Story I believe just weird to think
that like there's that Disney World then
there's also like square characters and
there yeah I always hoped that a Kingdom
Hearts sequel would actually it would
not be really marketable but we have so
much power right now
sorry no but it'll be it would have been
interesting to have Disney characters
travel to square worlds mm-hmm all right
so you got a message okay okay
well yes we're just doing what I don't
know we'll see what this quest is but
we're probably gonna wrap up here
shortly mm-hmm
so yeah Dan The News said oblivion made
him buy his xbox 360 nice I hear that's
a fan favorite among Elder Scrolls fans
I think someone said what up oh geez
he's being harassed by what to like
goblins demons
all right we're gonna let Miguel kill
these Damon's and get some final thought
from him I wrap it up for this fun ff15
multiplayer expansion comrades I'm sure
if you like 15 enjoyed it this seems
right up here right up your alley
potentially yeah I mean it definitely
feels like an extension of the main game
I like that you know being like an out
over an hour in that there seems to be
the implication that there's gonna be a
lot more press to take on and as I said
and as we talked about I mean between
this and the episode Ignace Gladius and
Prompto chapters plus all the other
add-ons like the Assassin's Creed
festival seems like a pretty darn good
value for the season pass yeah let's see
what this does
[Music]
okay must have been a lot of work
calling that thing all the way back here
good job glaive now my only question is
where the hell are we gonna put it Oh
what about the basement of the Laville
yeah I bet the king can rest in peace
down there speaking of rest you must be
beat it's written all over your face
maybe you ought to call it a night too
sick
sort of lucy's well you have liberated
my soul well I cannot lift the cross
that you bear I can offer my protection
and help shown for that burden I felt
like I should dress better for this oh
there's the signal no okay there you go
yeah I figured it was a quest item yeah
like it had to be cool we got the sigil
it's good that guys look cool
we'll say the loading is a little German
asking do the creative characters feel
unique or are they
combo palette swap you would have better
oh wow
are these all like or okay they are
these different sigils sorry won't you
answer that question before we look into
that stuff you just feel like it's a
combo palette swap or does your
character actually feel unique no it
doesn't feel like okay this are these
like all stewed jewels that you could
potentially have yeah I guess that looks
cool
well it seems to imply like if it's this
long to get one one yeah then you're
looking at maybe was that a 12 there
potentially a 10 hour playthrough maybe
more yeah because you could conceivably
grind as much as you want right right
for the hunts and more hunts will show
up so that's pretty cool yeah you're one
out of twelve minutes right now yeah
awesome Thank You Miguel so much for
playing today you kind of your first
impressions I guess of this so far dive
deeper or if yeah I mean if I had time
you know we're going into our best day
of Game of the Year slash discussions so
that stuff is uh definitely adding to my
workload but you know for me casually I
mean I'm playing at home yeah I could
see myself like getting into this now
you know the trophies are nice carrot
too and you know the all these signals
here seems to imply it there's there's a
lot going on I'm hoping that the quests
will be more than just monster hunts so
well you had those side missions to
select but yes we'll have to see how
much deeper it gets there but uh yeah
that was Final Fantasy 15 comrades
multiplayer expansion as mentioned if
you have the season pass already you
have access to this you can play it
download it just look for it in the
store under ff15 I think that's how you
did it right Miguel mhm if you don't
have it yet or if you don't have season
pass it's 1999 if you
want the expansion on its own or you
could buy the season pass which gives
you a nice little bit of value for
another five dollars or so but come back
tomorrow we're live every day at 11:00
tomorrow will be playing Skyrim on the
switch and then Friday of course as
mentioned by Miguel we are doing our
extra life stream of Palooza will be
live for 72 hours across all of our
territories UK Australia and the US and
so yeah if you want to stop by watch us
play some games do some silly things for
the for the kids and for the donations
stop by will also be doing a bunch of
giveaways can you remind us some of the
square stuff that's being given away
again Nier automata world of Final
Fantasy Final Fantasy 9 final fantasy 12
fantasy xiv so all that and more but
until next time guys thank you guys for
tuning in and hopefully see you tomorrow
and if not definitely Friday Saturday
Sunday of this weekend thank you guys so
much
peace out thanks
[Music]